لقد حققت شركتك طفرة كبيرة في مجال
الطاقة الشمسية بشكل أساسي ، فنحن
نصنع فرنًا شمسيًا بدرجة حرارة عالية ،
وهو فرن شمسي يعمل
بألف درجة مئوية بحيث يكون
أكثر سخونة من فرنك النموذجي ولكن في
درجات الحرارة هذه يمكننا القيام بهذه
الصناعة الخطيرة  العمليات التي
تطلق الكثير من ثاني أكسيد الكربون مثل صناعة الأسمنت
وصنع الزجاج مما يجعل كل تلك
الصناعات التي لا تستخدم
الكهرباء تستخدم فيها الحرارة ولم يكن ذلك
ممكنًا في السابق من الطاقة الشمسية وأخيراً
يمكننا فعل ذلك وتقليله حقًا
انبعاثات ثاني أكسيد الكربون على نطاق صناعي
، أزمة المناخ هنا
ليست مشكلة افتراضية يعتبر الأسمنت
أحد أكبر المذنبين في
توليد ثاني أكسيد الكربون ، وإذا كان بإمكاننا بالفعل
توليد حرارة على نطاق صناعي يحتوي
على طاقة الشمس ، فهذه
فرصة نفكر فيها حول الطاقة الشمسية  الطاقة
مثل الألواح التقليدية على
أسطح المنازل ، هل يمكن أن تخبرني كيف يختلف Helio Gen
عن هذا النوع من
الطاقة الشمسية التقليدية
اللوحة الشمسية التقليدية  يجعل حوالي
25 في المائة من الطلب العالمي على
الطاقة من الكهرباء عبارة عن كهرباء تعمل على تشغيل
مصابيحنا وأجهزتنا وما إلى ذلك من
حرارة المصافي التي تعد الشكل السائد
لاستخدام الطاقة والشكل السائد
للانبعاثات مثل الألواح الكهروضوئية أو الألواح الشمسية
أنك تضع على سطح منزلك
لا يمكنها أن تجعل الحرارة المرتفعة
التي تحتاجها الصناعة ، لذلك نشعر حقًا
أننا أول شركة توفر
درجة الحرارة المرتفعة للسوق الأكبر ،
كيف تمكنت من الوصول إلى
درجات الحرارة المرتفعة هذه  نحن في الأساس
نأخذ المرايا ولدينا مرآة
تعكس ضوء الشمس ولكن لدينا
الآلاف منها جميعها مضبوطة بدقة
مع برنامج لعكس شعاعها الشمسي
إلى مكان واحد الآن إذا أخذت
مرآة واحدة وعكس الضوء إلى
بقعة ستصبح دافئة  ولكن إذا أخذت
ألف مرآة وجعلتها تتماشى
تمامًا مع نقطة واحدة ، يمكنك
تحقيق درجات حرارة عالية للغاية ،
لذا كان اختراقنا عبارة عن
تقنية لمحاذاة الكمبيوتر الكل
أشعة الشمس إلى مكان واحد لتحقيق
درجة الحرارة المرتفعة التي تفتح
هذا السوق الجديد بالكامل هذه الصناعة الجديدة بالكامل ،
لذا فأنت تستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي
للمساعدة في محاولة حل أزمة المناخ ،
نعم هذه هي الطريقة التي نخفض بها التكلفة
للتغلب عليها  الوقود الأحفوري الوقود الأحفوري
غير مكلف للغاية لأننا نحفره
من الأرض ، والطريقة الوحيدة للتنافس هي
أن تكون ذكيًا للغاية في كيفية
استخدامك للمواد ، وباستخدام البرامج
التي تكون قادرًا على القيام بذلك ، من الواضح أن القياس
سيتطلب قدرًا معينًا من
رأس المال
باتريك ، هل ستستثمر
أكثر في هذه الشركة ، فهذه
مشكلة وجودية لأطفالك
وأولادي وأحفادنا أعتقد أن على
شخص ما تصعيد الحكومة
يجب أن تكثف القطاع
الخاص ، والأهم من ذلك أن العلماء
يجب أن يتقدموا  حتى الاتصال بالمساهمة
، الجواب هو نعم تمامًا ،
ما هو مذهل هو فاتورة ، وقد استغل الفريق
هنا بالفعل الشمس
ويستخدمها فعليًا في القيمة الاسمية
تكلف البشرية
إمكانات هائلة للأعمال التجارية
لا يمكن فهمها في هذه المرحلة